remember that one tweet by joe jorgensen
uh tyler i don't know if you have it or
not
and all of a sudden we get this tweet
about uh what do you call it uh
uh racism and black lives matter and we
need to be
so if you can make that it's not enough
to be passively not racist we must be
actively
anti-racist black lives mate standing in
a solidarity with a morning black
community as we fight together to
unqualify immunity police brutality
sentencing disparities and the war on
drugs not support of any organization by
by that name okay so to me i see that
and i uh i don't know how you guys
process it i'm gonna speak for myself
you guys can say pat you're full of you
know you have no clue what you're
talking about
i see that
and i see somebody caving in to pc
community and you know political
correctness just kind of like hey
beating you down you better get with us
okay let's throw this out there so maybe
we can get some independent voters who
are
agreeing with black lives matter okay
let's throw so i can get some of the
democratic voters who come yeah so that
that argument then then all of a sudden
the people that are true libertarians
are like wait a minute
that's not what i believe in i'm out
well i mean look i was very vocal and
very critical about that tweet as well
as a bunch of other ones it was just
yeah it was just awful and completely
tone deaf i mean it's also like she said
it while
the longest sustained riots in modern
american history were going on i mean
it's like
you know like people were terrified in
almost every major city across the
country businesses being destroyed and
then it's just like well it
it's also not libertarian at all the
libertarianism really has nothing to say
about how you feel
about other people if you are passively
not racist that's more than good enough
we don't require anyone to be actively
anti-racist whatever that means um the
truth is that look i was very critical
of george joe jorgensen during this
campaign i think that's why a lot of her
people around her don't like me very
much and why they gave her some bad
information that she came and shared
with you on the show um but i think that
it does
libertarians if we're gonna look like to
the fundraising issue before i think as
far as national candidates go the the
truth is that um ron paul at the time
broke fundraising records uh bernie
sanders then came in and smashed those
yeah and they didn't do it by going to
private equity guys
6 million on myspace and 24 hours that's
right that's right ron paul yes it was
and it broke records and he didn't even
set it up he literally just got into the
camera and said things that people
really appreciated and so what i think
is that the role for libertarians here
is that we're not going to out-compete
democrats and republicans in terms of
getting more money from private equity
or big banks or something like that
because we're not offering them what
democrats and republicans are the truth
is that if the libertarian agenda were
to ever be put in place big banks would
make way less money than they make right
now we're the party who wants to abolish
the federal reserve and make sure
there's never banker bailouts again and
that they don't have unlimited access to
easy money and that they can you know
like yeah i bet if if i could borrow
money at zero percent interest rate and
then loan it out to the public uh for at
four percent i could do pretty good
making money too but we're trying to end
that scheme but what we can do is talk
to the american people who are being
ripped off by this whole system and get
them excited so that's so the problem
with joe jorgensen is that when you're
so out of touch with what's going on in
the culture right now and you just say
something like this that rightly by you
is perceived as caving in to a literal
mob um that doesn't get them riled up
in this time period while joe jorgensen
is tweeting that the american people
have the government has perpetrated one
of the greatest crimes against the
american people in modern american
history which were the lockdowns kicking
tens of millions of people out of work
with no legal justification just under
emergency powers govern governor decrees
we're many dictators now it's illegal
now for you to go to work and at the
same time they have raped the american
people just completely looted the
treasury and bailed out every giant
corporation in the country it was like
the most heinous crime committed against
the american people and in that moment
to stand up and say you know what the
problem is you average american you're
not anti-racist enough
that's the real issue that's what
libertarians have to say
yeah i mean i lost all my income
immediately i mean i bled through my
savings in about four months i mean the
the um the closures the coveted closures
are definitely what red pilled me so
hard um i think uh joe's tweet is just
indicative of the old format
of libertarians trying to court both
sides
of it of the social of the um the
culture war but we're so deep into it
now that if you don't know that what
you're d if you don't define what the
dna of libertarian
libertarianism is today
like how do we standardize any type of
messaging because that's very contrary
to the opinions of like people on this
panel that want to see libertarians move
more to the right on these issues well
and also i agree with that and also just
kind of knowing where your best
potential you know tar like i want
everyone to be a libertarian but i could
also recognize that there's certain
groups that are probably a little bit
more likely to respond to our message
and what you have going on if you if you
have your finger on the pulse of the
country is that you had um you have a
lot of people like on the political
right half of the country who align with
a lot of our views a lot of people who
really are fed up with like the wars and
the the deep state all the three-letter
agencies that that are fed up with the
lockdowns that are i mean even after all
the republican governors by and large
were awful on the lockdowns we talk
about like the two who were good like
desantis and and gnome the rest of them
all basically went along with the
program um and then you have a bunch of
people who historically have been more
left liberals who are completely turned
off by all this woke insanity and are
kind of leaving that so what you're
playing to with this message is the
people who what love the woke insanity
and our left liberals right this of all
the groups this is the least likely to
bear fruit for you so it's just even on
top of it being incorrect it's also just
strategically
stupid
where i wonder like
who are you processing issues with
before you put a message like this
because you're speaking
on behalf of 4.5 4.6 million people that
voted for this
concept this philosophy just four years
ago like who you strategizing with to
say let's go and do this that's what i
was asking about spike but jessica you
voted for obama 08 right you were you
were you were more on the liberal side
democratic side so what caused you to
say because everybody's selling their
philosophies what got you to the tipping
point to say you know what i kind of
like what these guys stand for
um
just on joe's tweet again do you think
that's indicative of the fact that she's
an educator and we know how woke the
how woke that went so big education i
would just like to weigh in joe has
didn't even know that was made it was
from a a speech that was written for her
at the convention and they clipped it
for the tweet so i i just want to make a
point that like she didn't do that i
don't know how joe jorgensen's never
been on her twitter but but i do want to
talk about this
by the way what you just said yeah what
you just said i hate to say this
eliminates her from ever running as the
face of the libertarian party what you
just said right there because if you
can't speak for yourself i'm sorry i
don't want i don't want you at the at
the white house and if you do outsource
that then it's your responsibility
i'm not cool with that i want to know
what you're all about so
you were saying
in the wake of the killing of george
floyd and brianna taylor and the
protests and the riots that that sparked
there was an excellent opportunity for
libertarians to talk about the same
system that had uh unaccountable police
officers that were doing those things as
well as that same criminal justice
system that was letting people take over
entire communities and riot and pillage
and burn down buildings and homes it was
a great opportunity to do that
that's what should have been done that's
what i was trying to do in my little
corner is saying the same system that
this group's mad at is the same system
that this group is mad at and we should
be talking about that instead of playing
to the uh black lives matter versus all
lives matter culture war good cop bad
cop routine saying you're all being
scammed and lied to the way forward is
to fix these specific policies or end
these specific policies that led to what
we're experiencing right now and if we
do that then we can both reach to people
across the board we can actually have a
moment of unification and we can wake up
some people that are looking at all of
this and saying i don't think anyone is
speaking to the actual solution to this
when you go once hard one side or the
other when you when you start uh using
too much of the the verbiage and the and
the the tone and narrative of one side
or the other you're signaling well i
actually kind of support this side well
if you're trying to get elected then
you're basically saying yeah i'm like
this guy except i'm less likely to win
or i'm like this guy except i'm less
likely to win but if instead you provide
a stark contrast and say no no here's
why they're both wrong i hated when i
would get interviewed and they'd say do
you agree with trump on this or do you
agree with biden on this and i'd say
here's why they're both wrong and here's
what libertarians believe and that was
the problem with that tweet and with a
lot of other things is that instead of
trying to provide a stark contrast
between the republicans and democrats
and how they both work together to fail
us on this instead it was well on this i
agree with this side more and on that i
agree with that side more well why are
we relevant then so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]